bonjour eric valette bonjour vous êtes
le dis aux deux des onze candidats en
course pour ces sénatoriales du 24
septembre candidat divers gauche a envie
de dire divers gauche seulement parce
que vous auriez pu obtenir le soutien du
rassemblement démocratique martiniquais
de claude lise dont vous êtes un proche
vous n'avez pas demandé cette soutien
non je crois que ce type d'élections
nécessite un large rassemblement puisque
nous nous adressons aux représentants
locaux du peuple martiniquais à sa voix
des grands électeurs et donc et ce sont
des personnes très politisée qui ont
leur appartenance partisane et je crois
que cette élection doit être l'occasion
pour nous de ramener le débat
la wii doit être parce qu'il ya de très
gros enjeux qui nous interpellent et il
n'est donc pas question que nous
puissions nous enfermer dans un clivage
tout en souhaitant quand même ne pas
nous éloigner de notre idéal de gauche
eric vallet vous avez entendu toutes ces
remarques toutes ces critiques tous ces
reproches concernant le passage d'irma
que fait le gouvernement que fait la
présidence que fait l'état que font les
pouvoirs publics
est-ce qu'il appartient parlementaire
par exemple un sénateur d'intervenir a
peut-être en amont lors de la
préparation des choses lors de lors de
la préparation de dd gestion de crise
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire concernant ce qui se passe à irma
est ce que on a mal fait les choses
est-ce que c'est aux politiques
d'intervenir pour améliorer le système
eh bien je crois que cette réponse peut
être à deux niveaux tout d'abord je veux
exprimer toute mon émotion par rapport à
la souffrance la misère suite que vivent
les c'est martine oil les guadeloupéens
même je pense les martiniquais face à
cette catastrophe naturelle
ce rapport sur le problème de
l'anticipation c'était de la prévention
et moi je crois que nous nous rendons
compte que nous ne sommes pas préparés
nous sommes insuffisamment préparés
savons plus faire face à ce genre
d'événement puisque nous sommes en zone
tropicale
nous savons que la théâtre en nous
savons que 17 ans arrivent nous avons
risque le volcanique
nous savons aussi que
mais c'est dangereux pour la santé nous
savons que l'alcool ça peut provoquer la
cirrhose etc bref il ya des choses que
nous savons
mais la préparation passe par
l'éducation ce fait nous devons adapter
notre éducation populaire à la réalité
de notre environnement
au delà de l'éducation nationale et
celui qui vous parle est un militant au
quotidien puisque je préside le vaste
mouvement familial martiniquais 40
associations familiales
je suis un projet un tout la
circonstance puisque je suis candidat
roger derue mais hors projet de l'udf
voilà concept du daf
mais nous avons la dimension c'est la
question de la préparation pot pour moi
en tout cas est centrale si vous avez
une population qui qui emportés par le
vent va dire le vent de la consommation
le vent de la soumission soumission par
rapport aux phénomènes naturels
soumission par rapport à à la
structuration même de l'économie
soumission par rapport au marché du
travail
en tout cas aux faibles aux offres et
bien une population surprise est une
population battue est plus que jamais le
parlementaire quand il va au parlement
ce n'est pas pour passer à côté je crois
de ces débats qui sont nécessaires et
quand il n'existe pas il faut les
provoquer ce à dire que tout
parlementaire à la à une capacité est
une force de proposition est ce à dire
eric valeur que si vous étiez élu à la
chambre haute vous combat trier cette
idée qu on ne peut pas laisser par
exemple dans nos îles plusieurs systèmes
se développer deux côtés une population
très riche très aisée et à côté une
autre population qui vit dans les
ghettos
ben c'est tout ce qui fait que moi je me
réclame de l'idéal socialiste et
humaniste
nous ne pouvons pas vivre dans une
société surtout exigu avec de tels
stratification et donc j'estime que la
politique sociale
qui doit accompagner j'allais dire
l'encouragement à l'initiative privée
jédir économie est bien cette politique
sociale ne crois pas être reléguées au
second plan mais une politique sociale
sans une préparation sociale et bien
tout cela va se heurter à des limites
lorsque vous avez décidé de vous
présenter à cette élection sénatoriale
rivale n y avait pas encore irma n'y
avait pas encore josé est ce que c'est
les événements de ces derniers jours
vous amène à revoir les arguments que
vous pourriez proposé auprès des grands
électeurs pour tenter de les convaincre
de les séduire de voter pour vous non
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les grands
électeurs
je ne veux pas leur présenter des
arguments en fonction des circonstances
les arguments bas je les ai depuis un an
depuis l'annnonce de du renouvellement
de la représentation nationale puisse de
la république députés sénateurs en 2017
nous sommes au dernier rendez-vous où il
va falloir pouvoir le sénat d'une
renouveler la moitié des sénateurs
il se trouve que les deux sénateurs de
martinique sont sortants moi je propose
une autre catégorie de parlementaire je
ne veux pas dire par là que les autres
étaient de mauvaise catégorie mais une
catégorie de parlementaires bien
imprégné si vous voulez de ce qui serait
indispensable pour notre pays en un jour
c'est ce jeu c'est l'emploi par exemple
je siège au conseil municipal du
lamentin je suis un élu de l'opposition
mais je me refuse de tirer argument de
ce que notre ville pourrait être
confronté à des difficultés financières
parce que je suis de l'opposition j'en
connais la cause la cause c'est le
retrait des poulets des finances
publiques auprès l'éloignement de l'état
l'état a largué les collectivités
locales et salia de mal en pis donc moi
en tant que parlementaire jeudi à l'état
en tout cas face au promu que l'état
c'est nous l'état c'est le système
démocratique l'état c'est la qualité de
sa représentation nationale veuille moi
je dis à l'état au parlement
écoutez il faut revoir l'organisation
territoriale de la république et moi je
suis un partisan saisir east intégral
pas intégriste je suis un partisan de
l'autonomie régionale ces listes vous
êtes progressiste et de la france
antilles du jour on voit que vous êtes
également démocrate ce sont des notions
que vous juxtaposez les uns contre les
autres pour séduire plus largement je
peux même ajouté je suis patriote je
peux même ajouté je suis humaniste
je peux même ajouté que je suis un
chrétien vous savez je respecte
énormément la laïcité
tout ceci est une cohérence c'est
l'unité d'un homme qui se présente c'est
à dire qui se présente et il s'exprime
tel qu'il vit au quotidien
mais c'est un homme qui observe
l'évolution de son pays depuis quelques
années nous sommes dans une situation
bloquée il faut trouver une porte de
sortie de se rompre et puisque vous dis
que nous sommes dans une situation
bloquée l'assemblée de martinique une
institution qui à peine à peine quelques
mois - deuxièmement en tout cas
d'existence penser qu'il faut déjà agir
sur cette assemblée parce que ça ne
fonctionne pas par exemple la relation
conseil exécutif est assemblé de
martinique il faut être indulgent
indépendamment de la majorité qui la
gouvernent par rapport à cette nouvelle
institution
mais l'indulgence ne signifie pas
l'endormissement
moi je crois que cette assemblée a
besoin d'améliorations au lieu de dire
que celui-là président a semblé moins
influent que le président du conseil
exécutif
au lieu d'essayer de chercher lépine qui
pourrait piquer le voisin le frère leu
leu leu leu compatriotes
puisque nous sommes tous des
compatriotes eh bien il faut se dire la
loi du 27 juillet 2011 qui institue sept
collectivités territoriales de la
martinique at elle tout prévu et il faut
pas rougir de ce qu'on n'ait pas pensé à
tout donc vous voulez revoir les choses
confiants dans leur relationnel
quand l'effectif a semblé absolument
quand je vous dis que pour dire poursuit
paul autonomie régionale globale
moi je souhaite que cette loi évolue par
les institutions vin vous parvenez dans
le débat institutionnel
nous avons une loi je crois qu'il part
d'une bonne intention
sommes régis par l'article 73 de la
constitution c'est le peuple qui l'a
voulu et puis cette loi doit être une
loi qui nous permette de de mettre en
place les conditions d'un gouvernement
régional local
les deux présidents deux premiers
ministres un président et un premier
ministre à l'article 113 la constitution
un président un premier ministre local
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale
locale le président étant le chef du
parti majorité le président et le chef
de la majorité mais ils gouvernent
l'ensemble des élus et puis il doit être
à l'écouté de l'ensemble du territoire y
compris des collectivités locales des
communes
le rôle lui le premier ministre j'ai eu
le conseil exécutif le rôle du sénateur
en est il pour vos moments on dit trop
dit lui qui coûte cher à la nation et
dont l'action n'est pas assez visible
on l'a entendu lors des dernières
élections plan national que ce soit la
présidentielle et législatives pour moi
ce sont des arguties
ce n'est pas en réduisant l'assemblée
nationale en deux ce n'est pas en
réduisant le scénar par deux divisant
par deux que nous allons régler les
problèmes fondamentaux de la france
le problème fondamental de la france
c'est le problème du parlementarisme
ils veulent et je peux parler
d'oligarchie ge
les autres n'ont pas le monopole de
l'oligarchie
ils veulent réduire la fonction
parlementaire
tout simplement pour agir à côté d'une
école qui serait un chef de l'état
providentiel
moi j'estime que cette aspiration des
très mauvaises et des tons recul pour
notre démocratie est encore pire pour
nous autres marins merci eric valeur
rappelle que vous êtes l'un des onze les
rides en course pour les élections
sénatoriales du 24 7 ans merci bonne
journée merci
[Musique]